[Music]
each
[Music]
in the world
[Music]
keep stat I'm told me to point at it
it's not gonna catch me off-guard this
time hello hey what's up everybody happy
Friday have a community Friday yeah
we've made it again
QT Friday's back friend
we brought a friend me Jake Decker cuz
it's Smash Bros day yes Smash Bros day
that is right today we're playing Smash
Bros with you guys because by lifting
out everyone's favorites new smash
character sword-swinging character is
back with actually really like the way
viola plays I do too I have a disclaimer
to make though okay when we've done this
previously I was deep into smash I
played a lot of Smash Bros I was good at
smash bros i was at my peak i haven't
played in a while so yeah we'll see how
this goes
I like violet not very good with
violence I'm gonna start with violet
just you know see what's up see ya see
how see how it goes and then I'll
probably switch to one of my safer bets
sounds good alright I don't why you
switch over to our lovely setup we got
going so if you want to join us right
down below we have the name of the
battle arena we made the password along
with the ID so please come join us come
on in and play with us and building off
of Jake's disclaimer is a good time to
remind everyone to that community
Friday's isn't about being worried about
being too good or too bad we're just
kind of hanging out having a good time
if you have any sort of second guesses
about wanting to join put them aside and
just come on in
yeah every time we played Mortal Kombat
it's a good indication oh yes we enjoy
playing Mortal Kombat but there are
people out there who are much much
better at Mortal Kombat than we are and
that's okay I will say how this room is
set up is that it's it's just so we can
get as many people through it it's 1v1
mm-hmm
loser drops one stock so these rounds
are gonna move fairly quickly if you've
done no other community Friday's with
smash that's how we typically do it
however if if you're really good and
trouncing on everyone game after game
after game after a while maybe step-down
maybe just like suicide off the off the
platform and let other people get in
there because
right from experience one thing that
does get kind of tiring is when it's
just one person like just showing off
for 30 minutes or so yeah yeah half the
appeal of the show I feel like as people
are like I want to be GameSpot yeah and
this is your chance but yes so I've only
played viola for a little bit myself as
well uh I really enjoy them yeah mr.
sleep wants to know if violet is Opie uh
do I need to say my first reaction was
there gonna be a problem I think but I
think it's also just it's a new
character but baby you have to show your
take my take right you said and you're
like I've said it and I'll never stop
again but I'm putting you on the spot
and I'm gonna make you say it again so
bye love is an interesting Fire Emblem
character because they come from a
tactics based series where you have to
take your time to think and violet I
think is also maybe like the slowest
hitting like character from fire on them
yet so you've gotta be have to land on
your attacks what you got to do exactly
it's like you get you can't just commit
to doing a down B and you know it's
gonna work you've got a plan that's up
so accomplices they're trying to join
but they keep getting unable to connect
to the other consoles huh
you know a bunch people trying to join
right now but they're saying they're
having issues not working I can start a
new writer made me one yeah
you want to try that shrink down the
arena all right sorry yeah you got to
change the ID the word that's Evan in
the back by the way yeah a wonderful
switcher for the day
seven thank you happy to be
we are using a wired connection right
but then we are bugbear we're wired I'm
just gonna name this yes I don't want to
put in actually although I guess it
shows that pump because it's soon as
it's used to it and password is still
gonna be 42069 because we're children
here of course I don't know you're
talking about like this guy bro I'm at
work just got you a towel
tell them you're taking an early lunch
break so the idea is for one of the bats
which I I did that a couple of times and
I was here as I'd bring in my 3ds and I
just go on my lunch break and just like
get one of the free drinks from the the
break room and just played my three
guests mr prevel says i hope this is
still happening in three hours i want to
try it and fortunately we don't go that
long yeah least it's still a thing that
i think about like doing later later
streams for for community Fridays
because it is to the middle of the day
on a Friday yeah
[Music]
I mean like well if we did it'd be like
1 3 or 4 you get a comment I just pasted
again the same error okay let me reset
smash bros because when we fired it like
we've changed the connection so many
times since we've launched it so maybe
that's the issue
oh sure and then if worse comes to worse
we'll just just restart the whole system
to start all over from beginning some
bizarre error wonder if that's looking
like a net code thing or yeah I don't
know mmm I feel like we've done it
before though yeah maybe it's not in
this room but like I think we're doing
this room I think we did it one time in
this room yeah yeah back when there was
a whole whole table still here yeah that
was like 2 years ago though one thing I
remember about Smash Bros on the Wii U
is that the startup took longer and
longer every update let's get me the
point where this game like you start it
and it's just black for a while like uh
you working a lot of meat costumes I'm
also wondering if maybe the passwords
yeah should I not do a password I tried
not doing it not to password we could
because I mean I feel like at this point
if you're if you're looking for yeah
yeah
yeah use those keywords a community
fireball all right okay no password
nothing that words maybe that'll help
new ideas 63w
that's a pretty easy one to remember now
watch people just start flooding in it
was the password entirely maybe or the
reset chute
we've adjusted too many factors for the
scientific method or
I'm ready for
feeling it any second now if it's still
happening I have one more thing I could
try okay
and all involve me running a cable ooh a
cable a cable run to have people seeing
their jobs either joining someone joined
since it's working maybe try again
sonic got in whoa will do this round
yeah and then hopefully more people will
joined by the time this rounds over if
not this guy just got lucky or girl yeah
but if everyone in the chat staying
there getting an error then after this
we can I can try different Sonic's too
fast for me
Sonic it's gonna be too fast there's no
way so the first one of the day you
gotta give um done all these these
network errors you've made a soft
there's too many people are trying to
join except for Sonic because it's so
fast that's a sin checks out yeah
[Music]
all right but all the weight talk to
this match is over
[Music]
whoa
[Music]
yeah even commented a course Jake violin
[Music]
[Applause]
and not just because that was quick like
the yellow black
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
also just dang so I don't like I don't
like by especially maybe it's just but
I'm playing in Sonic right there but by
it's too slow for me yeah that was kind
of like the extremes of Miller's hands
full now maybe it certainly doesn't look
full yeah it doesn't look full to me
okay what do you hop on out okay I'm
gonna do that the cable run oh shoot we
got a jungle people in happening benches
we play a couple matches then while he's
doing that I'm here
ten and ten second match quick time now
I hit the wrong one
you still got time we'll do one v12 or
one life he's already dead of mine he's
already God can't believe this
I also get up we're going a little bit
that's a very good call all right so
with this cable magic okay do you want
to double-check the internet connection
on the well actually if you do that Evan
can you go to full count for a sec this
is my favorite part of comitia Fridays
is when we're getting all of the
connection stuff sorted I'm really
stoked how well Master Chief collection
worked out laughs no that's like our
most that an Xbox the Xbox one almost
never over tell no issues okay but yeah
what does an anti be mean moderate maybe
that's that that middle ground not the
best but definitely not the worst all
right let's try this the game probably
just for safety we don't know the zero
to death combo on Donkey Kong why would
you want to zero to death Donkey Kong
ever he's a great guy
see
my hot spot to play this that's the
that's the kind of dedication I'm here
for him that's awesome
when when you want to smash so bad that
you've got a hot spot your game in
alright I mean you could probably search
back over I used to do that like when I
was traveling or like cuz especially
with the switch and I want to download a
game I'll like set off hotspot and don't
do that long did that take it would take
a while but like I have unlimited data
at the phone plan I have his ancient and
I other data so I can use that I've got
people who are updating we should be
ready to come in in about 10 minutes
that's good to hear
Ivan's throwing out Master Chief or
smash you don't want at this point I'm a
down looking throw him in oh I'm waiting
for Daryl Daryl would would probably be
I feel like probably one of the higher
chance ones uh if you ask me a year ago
I would have said no but now I'm like
you know maybe there's there's a part of
me that cuz they've already gotten girl
into Soul Calibur yeah Soul Calibur and
he's like that that's all been an AAMCO
stuff so they've already like I hook
that out create that arena
all right everybody hopefully sore for
smash be solved our issues here all
right let's see let's find out VPS a lot
of people in store for smash if ifs or
gets added to smash my reaction would
probably be similar to a lot of people
were disappointed with violet
I would accept I wouldn't say all the
terrible things and throw a fit I would
be disappointed yeah I my first initial
reaction was just kind of like being let
down and then I stopped and thought
about it and I was like you know I see
people joining this is it's working oh
my gosh your cable magic is too strong
I'm gonna do another violet try it again
you know you know you know what it was
we're plugged into the normal office and
probably yeah that's why why we can't
play Ubisoft games in the office hey
it's better than some of the offices
though around the world they can't even
get on like any of that they can't they
can't check like they can't check like
like game sites yeah she's like hey I
need this for like my job for news oh
yeah it's a wacky thing like to our like
company stuff plus people who can work
on YouTube things too long have access
to YouTube in it so I have to like hack
work our way around getting in yeah yeah
when I was in that when I was in the New
York office
Mike mihari was like oh yeah if you need
he's like a site like a talker or
something for like looking up something
you're gonna have to like do this work
around and I was like what
okay well everyone seemed to get in so
this is awesome we got that thing f0
going yeah yeah oh good I think it's
just like Sonic being way too fast
the UM the redirect you can do with her
her hammer
it's like Iraq seems like you shouldn't
be allowed to desert I'm trying to
figure out what the downside to that is
and I don't know if it works like just
like the wizard punch that game for
Ganondorf as though if it like kind of
the damage but I think it gets rid of
like the armor or something there's got
to be something to it because I've been
hit out of it before I'm not sure
because when you're playing a couple
days ago
like Michael would just be like I'm
gonna dodge behind you and then I'd be
like doesn't matter yeah the bailiff is
very fun in like 78 player matches
because you just yeah yeah I think
that's where like violet is probably
ideal is multiple people because like
people just can't predict some of this
stuff yeah the met the best are be real
different one be one oh no let's all
pile if I'm playing that's it no more
violence for me great after dark episode
oh thank you there you go
I was listening to it earlier again
gaming nerd says Nic Cage for smash
that's directly
I know him this is a plan the arena
spool we got people on deck lined up
maybe if as people kind of get get their
chance to come in and fight we can can
move it around
people might leave but we'll try to get
as many people in as we can but it's
always it's always impossible tonight I
know game developments are and
everything to different and I'm sure
there's all sorts of factors why it's
limited to eight but I look at a game
like Mortal Kombat where you can have
like a lobby of a hundred people and I'm
like but why not why not yeah yeah I
can't you just do that I'm sure there's
a thousand reasons why how if I don't
catch the I want to spectate button like
right away and I can see these two
little pieces like right shock each
other
speaking of really cool lobby systems we
finally got a US release date for grand
blue fantasy it's the beginning of March
so oh wait it was yeah they just
announced that this morning after I was
just saying after this yeah I like was
it literally 30 seconds after you told
me that yeah released so that was fun
but I really like the lobby system that
they have set up and that especially for
what we do because you can physically
see every person so it's like ah go find
the giant tagger in the back and we'll
set up matches it like this fake arcade
cabinet
oh yeah so it's a good time let's have
some fun I like that
let's watch oh yeah oh yeah let's go
Little Mac and a donkey kong i am your
whenever i'm spectating you gotta try to
side with someone I'm a psychopath I'm
putting all my chips on them see I
wouldn't eagle to win because I want to
I want to get out to get the salt run
back that's fair
man
[Music]
low map has apparently just been living
at the bottom of like the official smash
to your lists for a while but cuz
recovery coach is terrible
yeah in a platformer fighting game
having leap recovery is is a very
dangerous thing the death way
Oh dr. song okay you smashed it does a
heck of a fight
locked in get a foul I'm uh I'm
wondering if maybe we expand out to two
stocks pink ones to one's real quick and
because we've done two before but I
think it was a little too yeah a little
too long or we've done two before I was
a little too long but after this or
after we could I go through again and
get kicked out of back I can change the
rules yeah
so the final one is changing in that's
nice yeah
all right so do we got going on carry on
donkey kong and off we got by with game
there we go
it's a dmitri before he comes punished
curious how uh people in the chat how if
we've been playing violet how they feel
about it yeah the thing I like is see
people after like the initial reactions
kind of playing the character bath
saying oh you know kind of foam like I'm
Way better than they know how to use
news quickly which I can't figure out
how to do
type of spittoon stuff will avenge its
miss oh man more splatoon yeah be nice
kind of kind of sad knowing that there
isn't any too much going on to anymore
now like the game still there but it
just like that's that's the pilot yes
that's it right there you saw it paint
it out right in front of you knowing
that you can take a fully charged Donkey
Kong punch and still be okay
[Music]
oh man I love that it did both the
screens for it to to make you think it
was gonna know oh I'm sure some people
would not like this but I feel like
Nintendo needs to take the like live
service approach with like a splatoon
and be like why don't you just have one
game that you're just constantly
updating especially - one - like were
looked identical almost yeah it was just
like they added new maps new new web it
was really just like hey we're gonna put
this game on the switch yeah it was
really more of an ultimate a no than a
two
it's great game but yeah I would I feel
like Nintendo kind of used to get a
little caught up on that stuff is like
that game sold pretty well though maybe
they'll try that with the next one I
would like that a next one because I
mean like did you see the sales for the
switcher like absolutely insane yeah and
I I mean they'll definitely make another
splatoon I know it sold well and then I
know it just has a very passionate
audience like they always have liked it
so much for it I can't imagine them
there's a lot of like I never realized
how I played Joker is until I was
watching me yeah he won evo last year
and everyone was all upset about our son
Wow in that that down-down a smash the
down a second good attendance if you'd
like to see more octo expansion stuff
for cooking like that kind of smile that
was really good yeah those games have
like a surprisingly good single-player
this it was designed by Mario I've seen
obviously Mario the planet one what's it
called Oh God galaxy galaxy the Mario
Galaxy people worked on how that makes
sense it's got yeah it's got a lot of
that same energy
all right
if I get in a match against DK in arena
I don't know if I should do the zero to
death because it's kind of unfair I'd
sing try it
show show it off I wouldn't rely on it I
mean play to win obviously cuz like you
know that's what you want to do but like
there's a point where you kind of cross
the line between like beta game and
playing a game it's just I'm the type of
guy who sits in a corner spams taunt a
whole bunch so I'm not the best ask
about being best played three houses if
so what I went with the golden deer
because back when everyone was kind of
doing stuff for the game it seemed like
no one wanted to play that one so that's
what I was excited to do and I don't
regret it
oh no Black Eagles and then I did I
don't wanna spoil it but I did and I'm
halfway through gold but I've been
moving slow I started golden deer and
then I never I only played like five
hours I'd like to go back to it yeah
that's oh I feel bad that I kind of
dropped it it's it's it's a very good
game but it's for me at least it felt
like I was like I was exhausted at the
end of every time I played it
Tahlia especially those battles at the
end yeah like near the end where they
take like an hour to get through and I
would like have to save mid-battle and
pick it up the next day and then I'd
make a mistake and have to start over
because I like oh I guess I could rewind
time so it wasn't too bad but yeah it
was around the time that I got towards I
guess like the last third
game I literally want to wrap the whole
thing up we're playing 25 like 25 hours
in one weekend whoa I was like I need to
see this through and it's getting really
good it was a pretty good time in my
life but I also like started to see the
matrix at that point I just didn't think
about I was doing
all right are you Candida team can't
eric team oh man I forgot his name
okay rule I've got to be I got I got to
pick my Donkey Kong representation when
they announced him I got real excited to
it was like yeah he's kind like not
though before front of people who I want
to make it a smash but in the back of my
mind a lot of people wanted them to
Italy yeah it's definitely one of those
that like people asked for it and I I
think everyone's kind of assumed that
wouldn't actually begin it yeah yeah
hidden like Ridley yeah Ridley
especially because I was like how would
that even make sense happens right they
did it they hit it and no one plays them
yeah yeah I know I haven't played in a
while I get it
[Music]
how's that good back and forth yeah I
love when you kind of get those those
weird like oh oh
shot him ow Wow dethroned kill extra had
I had a good run now it's almost made it
to the whole thing
yeah I made the whole thing because I
think mobos so I played it first and won
I think or maybe not actually says they
missed Bergeron stream this week the
operations not been in my fancy her
she's been working on video stuff is
that what it is yeah she's been she's
working some other stuff
all right now she's still around some
cool videos coming out cool okay oh God
Tim's trying to get in
I've been pressing extra 10 minutes I've
never seen opening spot if you've been
in here for a little bit why don't you
hop on out so that a couple other people
can get on in just keep it going
okay there's kind of a weird bit of me
that like wishes there is an option for
you get like whoever stays or loser
stays we do like host stays just like
everyone could get a chance to like why
cuz the ideas they want yeah for finding
us right but I also liked watching -
yeah
[Music]
oh that belly counter fuel was always
the best firebomb character back in it
all right we're back in it back in it
me
[Music]
it's a close one I agree yeah not a fan
of buyeth but uh give me some other
fireman characters already with violence
you know maybe that's maybe that's it
but like I feel like slow characters you
just never works super well ma'am you're
except for Bowser except for Bowser and
I think it's because Bowser's like role
is fairly quick for his size yeah and
like some of his moves despite his like
charge moves that take forever some of
them are pretty quick oh shoot Evan can
you green-screen anything anything put
put put like the after dark podcast in
the background while we're or smashing
it I didn't I didn't teach Evan how to a
green screen no we should be an option
for chroma there is there is an option
and then you just pick green and then
don't don't actually worry about yeah
it's all good
I keep forgetting the stages even in the
game Brendan went up we're gonna watch
the Super Bowl oh I'll probably catch up
with my roommates watch it nah I'm not a
big sports guy but no I'll probably also
work
you meet my girlfriend I'll write into
all the movies you know and stuff be my
girlfriend like sometimes we'll like
turn it on cuz we're prone opponents
clap yeah it's just fun to be like hey
let's make some wings and food let's
just take in the excitement bits of it
it's just an excuse to make some like
greasy food yeah
you don't never mind yeah I'm watching
I'm watching the game I'm gonna eat a
bush dumb but uh no I'm sure there are
about know anyone here who like like oh
I have a Super Bowl party come by yeah
will Carl on the engineering team you
know I had one I think last year and the
year before but he's not doing one this
year and I was like well I probably
won't watch it then yeah Eagles back at
it this is this is the run back right
he's although now that I moved to my new
place actually have space to have a
party but music oh my god
[Music]
Eagle is just on it yeah so I just
reminder that if you've been in for a
little bit please hop out so that a
couple other people can get in otherwise
don't have to start kicking yeah
otherwise we'll have to start kicking
people we're trying to be polite about
it right now but we do want to get that
cycle going and get everyone going in
actually I can't even kick people I
think I can kick everyone by the hole
[Music]
yeah I can't kick okay
whoa hello is that supposed to happen
technically we were supposed to turn
those lights off before we start with a
bit thank goodness so that works it's
fine
just got real ominous and it just like
reminded me like oh yeah we probably
shouldn't turn those off that's totally
my bad oh you're thinking about about
Bowser yeah
what does it do they wait for you so to
get back from picking your character
it's alright maybe heck yeah I like that
do I have to leave I mean it would be
very nice if you've been in for a while
just so that other people can get in
yeah
yeah I think if if I make it back when I
make it back to the beginning again Wow
yikes when I make it back to the
beginning again if anyone has been here
the whole time I might have to kick some
people out make room
nothing personal that that was
devastating
that was that was powerful also that
pose I've never seen that one before
it's it's a like almost like a it's jojo
pose adjacent that is jojo pose to jason
is lil mac a jojo by the way I'm gonna
finish it it's me do it dude hey I
finally get to start watching it again
yeah starting tomorrow
starting tomorrow all bets are off came
down you sit down Spencer's door like
it's Jojo time well John thank you John
appreciate it
we appreciate it good good fights though
I'm always excited to see someone
playing Donkey Kong because I feel like
after so many games of him not being
great he finally has a chance to shine
this is the best possible outcome for
this stage we've got the anime ending
song Mario Odyssey playing
[Applause]
[Music]
whoa my Odyssey is a good game we're
gonna see a fairy I never bothered to
get all whatever nine hundred moons or
whatever the heck yeah because it it
gets the point where they're literally
just placed like oh no y-you tripped
over trash bags so after I beat it I
like kind of went through and like maybe
I could do it and then I hit a point
where I was like this is just become
tedious and I'm not you know who did I
don't know if he got them all but he was
trying to I think we are close if not
actually did it was a nick margarita oh
yeah I remember he was like yeah at his
desk being like I'm gonna get all Albany
sleep I still think looking back at that
year I think I might for me personally I
mean yeah they're so different
yeah we're just just think about my time
playing ball then like I really really
liked playing Zelda Mario was it was
just a good time
maybe happy Meyer hats like a good piece
to it just constantly moving sell does a
little more
riding a horse on him yeah which is like
the point of that game yeah that's the
devalue it it's just like very different
[Music]
doo-doo-doo-doo Sano my boy is gonna
beat up a small child yeah Evan says
he's been thinking about replying my
Odyssey it does a very good music yeah
[Music]
people get a sequel to it soon Mario
Otteson oh yeah do you think they'll do
like a tune I think they will
well I don't know considering how old I
games sold I mean they did a galaxy -
you know I galaxy - better than galaxy
one yeah I mean there's only one way
again I feel like we can only make that
game better right I also just like that
it's it's designed philosophy was you
like the 3d games like 64 hears that
yeah it's very typically 6-4
[Music]
was a good year for video games a real
good year for video games
I'm very excited for this year this is
gonna be a good like it's kind of an
unknown here I feel like there's a
couple of like obvious things like no
cyberpunk and richer but and we'll cross
I can't wait yeah coughing I said
Witcher I met the last of us and the
last that's very excited for the last
but also I'm like I don't know what's
happening in the fall there's yeah half
of the year that we don't those new
consoles coming out what's happening I
like that's got to be where a lot of
those fall releases are right because
apart from cyberpunk and the Call of
Duty game which is definitely gonna
happen and Avengers right there aren't
really many announced fall games I
imagine you're all just waiting for
these consoles to get announced and then
yeah I think Ubisoft just gonna be like
Assassin's Creed and you know do you
think there's gonna be two Assassin's
Creed games cuz usually when there's a
new generation they'll do like here's
the next gen game and here's the old gen
game and usually a very big I don't know
if we'll do that this year I don't think
so I don't think they because they got
cuz I got watchdogs also still so I
don't they need to Assassin's Creed let
me ask let me a lot
I think what's he'll do is it'll just
come to both plot it'll come to the new
pounces and oh yeah that's the thing
Peter was mentioning that the other day
and I sort of agree we're like I'm
excited for new consoles but admittedly
like right now I'm not feeling that like
that hype the way I would with previous
generations because I feel like there is
just
[Music]
there is nothing so far that to me
that's screaming like all it's gone wild
look who knows what they're gonna have
my god I'm just not feeling that well
you're part of it to me is the fact that
like Sony still hasn't announced
anything we don't know any game like and
like the series x2 like what they say it
doesn't have isn't gonna have any
exclusive games until like that really
kind of knocks the like oh I mean like
so it's cool these games are gonna look
better on the series X since it'll be
the best way to play Halo infinite but
I'll still be able to play Halo X that's
way like I think I won't feel it until
sony announces their thing and we start
seeing what yeah totally I'm like
waiting for those press I'll see the
games
let's see more of the games me too
see I said they're working on some games
for next-gen though that are gonna be
pretty big
I imagine battlefield or Battlefront one
of the two okay Danielle and Tim are
still not getting in so why don't we why
don't we kick two people out after okay
none other games this week I had like a
weird like like I knew PSO is coming out
and then all a sudden I remembered it
and I started looking at things and I
started like I started setting our arch
at that
Gianluca iron just a whole bunch of like
did you know it crossed over with this
game for like half of the day yeah
Michael time doesn't need even need to
make a fake GA this time you could just
straight-up get a chase yeah and I fit
up that's that beat us halfway
dang I love Piranha Plants so cool
[Applause]
it is is going by real quick which is
good for what for the stock I'm in the
slot we could do to you try let me what
I get
alright I'm gonna kick people out this
time actually will it take me from the
rotation if I try to kick people I don't
know but let's let's try it I know
Eagles been in since the beginning sorry
Eagle alright so we're gonna have to not
be
is he playing though I don't kick him
always now he's not lying I think sorry
you go very sorry Eagle nothing personal
got you got good matches mobos been in a
while but I think he's playing right now
here she yelling an echo left on their
own all right so uh Tim and Daniel try
and hop on in ego we're very sorry if
there's room later please hop back in
yeah we're trying to make sure we get as
many people yeah I've noted Tim and
Daniel have been like in the chat for a
while asking to get in so my host bangs
one of them yeah it's with there's like
these spectator benches - yeah Tim says
are in their name is Zane
so hopefully okay Daniel was in
[Music]
I mean the case thing we do have we do
have two people so I'm you know I think
I moment wolf will go for now
if mobo loses - I might have to kick
mobo - because mobos been here since the
beginning as well but we'll never we
won't know until the end because in that
spectating you hate to see it yeah oh
yeah well let's up the stock as well
eagle eros saying we should probably hit
the stock I'm gonna do it after I get
kicked out because if I go into there
it'll kick me out to the waiting and I'm
already next in line
Oh gotcha gotcha alright yeah well we'll
change stock
Matt Daniel stolen get in dank Daniel it
was there no you were waiting for it
what we'll try to get you in oh all
right all right Jake Jake we'll fight
next
[Music]
heaviness is ten and ten out of ten joke
thank you I appreciate it
sorry little bro I forgot shred Bowser
lined up to go up yes this five I could
do the move
you should I could do the move uh-oh
that's not fine let's go let it even
outfit
Oh No let me see every frame of that
Thanks
you thought about it I thought about it
I really did but I was like
[Applause]
No oh that's her very tiny link I'm
gonna blame the lag on that yeah that
lag was rough yeah because you you had
that bed up and it just came out with
kind of a texture on buzzer that's
that's something else yeah so one thing
that's like rudra nintendo games is
they've gotten like HD like they still
cartoony but they just give them really
like high res textures on like Mario's
mustache and I'll never forget the first
time I saw the stitching of Mario's I
never thought that I'd see the day here
we are look at that oh my goodness it's
like it new I think says a young Johnny
Knoxville that's a new one this is a
classic matchup
James dress up for Travis touchdown
oh you would do a good traffic anime
he's into anime so you'd be perfect for
him yeah yeah I actually have always
wanted play the No More Heroes games but
I like have gotten rid of my weave by
the time thank you
I never play they need to pour that [ __ ]
to switch they really do especially with
three happening Daniel says they got it
and finally heck yes
his Daniel alias I would hope so
and again thank you guys for the people
who are stepping out to whatever we do
appreciate it again stand by if we ever
have like open spots later on and and
jump back in but we want to try to make
sure we get so many people as we can in
yep
we want as many people to say they're
better at smash bros exactly as possible
it's it's not a good community Fridays
unless we know we sent people home
knowing that they can tell their friends
when they come back into school or work
that they beat games well Smash Brothers
and then their friends say food well
yeah I buy my games from them the game
grumps now everyone's getting their
they're up B's kind of oh all right Jake
there's a good opportunity to up the
stock to do
allow me to demonstrate I choked it's
all good
[Music]
you didn't just see PETA just the stocks
it looks like we might have a spot to if
anyone is trying to get in or something
there
how skull voices I'm a big fan of you
guys so I'm looking forward to stepping
in the ring oh thank you thanks yeah oh
you can actually edit them on the fly -
that's fantastic
[Music]
oh I think it is booted everyone I don't
know what does it keep people out of the
fight if it's going I don't know Rana
plans others just waiting for you to get
back in your spot so you can that's miss
has bad Joe heck yeah there was there
was a banjo who made it to like the
finals in Evo Japan and I really most
beautiful
[Applause]
that made me happy
[Music]
also top-tier color for viola this is
this is a good mountains over there boy
the only bummer is that I wish you could
be the female Bible with that I know
this look look at first thing I did when
we got the car installed
whoa why can't I get this set up
[Music]
yes you can get those those wonder wings
out there yeah
I play banjo I've never played banjo yes
I still think the original banjo kazooie
is maybe one of the best collectathon in
existence because there's a lot there
but it's not too much where you're like
everything I wouldn't 100% yes it's it's
perfectly balanced also the music okay
like banjo I'm not the best person to
ask my be some school age but I feel
like anyone who's played he's passionate
about banjo if I say that right yeah I
wholeheartedly recommend
[Music]
Evan wants to know if you think there
should be a banjo remake or should the
original stay as is so we've got the HD
versions which I'm very okay with I
don't know if I'd want like a like
full-on remake I'm curious what type of
liver you should take with it like
what's that first shader tech gonna look
like yeah right or they'll be like you
know how they were like a hundred notes
each level o'clock worth or 300
something didn't you would want it to be
purely visual and no no [ __ ] I could
take you both with that I don't want
them to add like boobs or anything like
oh we put in all the moves from to e
into kazooie or something yeah I think
the HD version is a real good wonder
every time
[Music]
oh you'll love to see it
banjo with the wind and Christopher says
can I get in uh yeah just look for an
opening I think we'll start we'll drop
some people if they have been in too
long but I feel like everyone here is
got some pretty neat everyone's pretty
fresh very fresh so we might wait a
little bit before we remove people but a
definitely keep an eye on it someone
might have to like step out or something
- but we've got all the info up there
for you if you want to join Terry and
banjo this is a good fight - I like
Terry a lot - characters we never
thought we'd see in Smash Bros duking it
out in Smash Bros here they are I love
that you can literally point almost
everything in Smash who would have
thought this would have been in yeah 10
year old Lee wouldn't believe that if I
saw this if you showed it to a member
right
even like the Nintendo characters
surprise me like I remember thinking
like after playing the first Super Smash
Bros like you'd be so cool that it
Bowser but I doubt they do it and they
added it for melee and I was like [ __ ]
is amazing just like a boss character
you can't do that or like Mewtwo I'm
like the coolest Pokemon is now in yeah
what that's way cooler than Jigglypuff
that was and then I respected Jigglypuff
after playing like it bad yeah all right
[ __ ] the real deal I never I feel like
a fool for not ever thinking about I
don't know if that's the thing that
Franco like hasn't there-there moveset
but he he shot out of grenade egg and
grabbed it and then wonder wing while he
had it in his hand so didn't blow him
off but it did the extra damage
[Music]
Oh
the point-like ones always classic too
man I just want to know who the other
six fighters are gonna be over here
right
just tell us Sakurai it's you're already
working on him I love how he has to make
a note
every time saying like these have
already been decided so please your
suggestions won't make a bit yeah yeah
was there were there data mining the
latest update for like code names or
something like that for the next
characters and they did expand the slots
like beyond that yeah
apparently they're like 28 slots I would
be like yeah just let's keep doing this
until people don't care anymore people
still care every time a thing happens
it's always like the biggest news of the
day yeah I'm sure Sakurai prefers this
because it's probably a lot like better
of a work environment than like building
a whole new game maybe that was the plan
to like make this literally just the
version of it supported from here on out
that's kind of what I expected
especially being called ultimate I
figured this is like the Smash Bros
we're gonna get I agree I wonder if
they'll release a version in this
generation where it's like here's all
the DLC characters - I doubt they will
because Nintendo games never drop in
price that's very true I bet it'll be
$60 they're the only time they might
release like Super Smash Bros ultimate
edition of ultimate is is the next-gen
console that Nintendo has in Melbourne
they'll dick you don't do like a
Greatest Hits reprint sometime yeah but
think about people a it I'm the titling
for the rereleased version because they
could play like a like a Resident Evil
the opposite thing or they're like in
Rose ultimate kwame ultimate special or
in Japan it's called special ultimate oh
yeah because they have two different
movements but I would also be down for
just meant for those ultimate kiwami
so holding out for my prediction past
two is gonna be one buck been one for
cosmic for years I think I hope they add
Gina I hope that you too because the
people have been waiting for Gina this
is so long it's it's not even character
I'd be excited about that I was saying
people be excited about Tim wants to
know our prediction for the second
fighter pass Geno geralt another Pokemon
I don't know which one
Dante I still feel confident Dante can
make it in I feel like kirie kirie you
I don't think here you'd get in but I'd
walk into it that's something I don't
think he'll get in either but I just
have for Ben I appreciate it I think
Travis it's it's it's weird to be at the
point like for me where I think it's
difficult for me to pick characters to
be in smash because I have someone else
like yes man drove out is there another
Metal Gear character that you'd be
excited if they added well we got like
grey fox is an assist trophy already
he'd just be another Sauron character
like Raiden you do that I guess it'd be
he was in a play session also it's true
the original Battle Royale
[Music]
I feel cuz snake is so well done and
they somehow found a way to make him fit
here yeah and I feel like they're not
gonna add two characters from the
different series they're from a non
Nintendo you know how sure maybe nothing
it's true maybe maybe like the reason
why I think there'll be new pokemon is
dlc coming and they could come out with
that around the same time as dlc to get
the hybrid maybe like another Zelda
character for breath of the wild - yeah
because I don't know if you saw but the
battle pass says it's gonna end that'll
pass fighters pass - says it will end in
the fine print December 31st 2021 ok so
I imagine it'll be done before that but
like Brad seems like it'll be done
before 2022 so I was just thinking about
that because I feel like the big thing
people keep saying they want for a
breath of the wild - is a playful seldom
yeah whether that's like she's the
character or it's like a co-op situation
like so but the problem is that like
Zelda already exists in
yeah but you like a warrior's elbow but
you could pull like a like a link to
link kind of section and you could have
like a a specific breath of the wild
version of Zelda directed by veteran
okay he's very different textured I've
I've want to touch her in for a while
it's cuz I was always surprised that
Zelda didn't have her breath the wild
skin I thought that was super weird cuz
it's like wait you yea added a breath
while in Hyrule / I want to see like an
echo character pack or like an extra
costumes pack yeah it's like imagine if
I were into the gym like for $5 costumes
rooms yeah like give snake his big boss
outfit from they would definitely have
to make that separate from the fighters
past because people would be real upset
give me a funky Kong echo character for
Donkey Kong like the possibilities there
I think are really good and it probably
wouldn't be as much work as making a
whole new character and I would
definitely buy it without
second-guessing it head says Sam for
bridges heck yeah all of his moves are
just falling over and having boxes Frank
yeah you have you can only play them
when items are turned on because he has
to pick them all up and put them on his
back what if the baby starts crying he
has to hand it to the other character
and they have to be able to consult the
babies throws the baby at piranha plants
incapacitated oh my god this person's
way beyond us
[Music]
but this is this is all of water versus
plant fight I know how Pokemon works
this is in theory I should win but that
ain't happening those ninja kicks oh
yeah this person is out very good sir or
pile that was trying to get in for a
while okay we got combos on zach online
companies taking around
oh okay one that got one that's all I
needed
oh that was a good way to do that I'm
into it wasn't intense fight yeah when I
was just kicked my ass yeah maybe one of
the best Greg ninjas I've ever seen or
didn't see injure the whole thing is not
being seen
try think of like I guess it's hard to
think about it like it like what's like
a something no one would ever suspect
that would like show up and smash like I
can't want something that like nobody
not kagura not like nobody wants but
just like no one would even think would
be a possibility you know a Dead or
Alive
it's like Joker was a case where like
I'd even think about that when I was
Joker I was like like well Joker kind of
like to change the way I thought about
yeah exactly
why I think they may be planned it that
way to be like Joker's the one where
we're setting the the president and let
people know that totally anything yeah
that's what Reggie said right it was
like this is we want this to like show
how we're gonna go forward with this
body yeah so I definitely want ready
he's like that's who they dad to know
Aaron I remember that was the thing
people wanted for all
oh no they got in before we got in maybe
hmm as the problem is like I can't I
can't think of a character if it's one
that I would never suspect
I also another thing to kind of think
about is I don't know if they're gonna
add like modes like these sometimes I've
been doing I know that I think they've
said that they're not doing any more but
like it was kind of cool to like
randomly getting an update like Oh home
run contest is back well I think that's
if they do end up what we're kind of
saying where they're gonna port the game
over and like this will just be the
version they keep porting new systems I
would assume that's what they would add
right it would be like well because
we're just porting the game over will
now add like a whole new single-player
here's break the targets for every
character like this break the tartness
break the targets - yeah I'm down for
that
this is the downside to have a psychotic
fart great name
so there's oh Jesus I don't want to have
to fight this greninja next yeah they're
good so everyone in the chats cheering
them on there you believing you if we
got our line up here yeah you're you're
next
we've got 25 rounds so far that's pretty
good Eliot hey can you change the music
okay what should we do
I think I'd be quick firing them but
banjo banjo less surprise we should
reach out for them I'll face myself
rivers in the desert yeah there we go
yeah don't think about this I get why it
kicks you out if you're changing your
character if you're changing the rules
but why would does it do it when you
change music yeah it's a bit of a weird
thing all right psyche go for it you can
do this you believe in you I'm excited
to give persona 5 another go-around
to this year so never finished it at
first yeah me too
I love that game yeah I will never play
it again never it's too long I at least
at least while I'm here maybe maybe and
I don't know if sometime in the future
I'm not working here and then I have
time and I'm like you know I'm gonna
replay that cuz sure I definitely liked
it and I would replay to find the time
but I'm just like I'm excited to see
what persona 4 royal is gonna add but
also it's like I don't there's no way
I'm gonna have the time to do that just
talk about the real persona release
that's happening for scram scramble get
our Musso fix
I think if boy was coming to switch then
I would have been like all right I think
I can do this it's still weird to me
that it's not like it seems like a
perfect place for it
that's it scramble on a switcher now
scramble is is that just coming
everything
I think PlayStation living just
PlayStation all right because Xbox is
not a thing in Japan hey there they're
working on it they brought it the
breena's PSO which they already haven't
and they're bringing us the bringing the
opposite to the game oh man psycho I'm
I'm proud that you tried to do it with
violence - but man can anyone beat this
greninja can we I want to make sure
everyone gets a chance to fight this
greninja and if no one beats that
greninja sorry maybe well maybe we might
we might we can get more people
switching in yeah and you've already
proved yourself you're the champ both
today 5 consecutive wins yeah I'd say
that's you are at the champion at that
point
heck yeah more pilots bring them in and
along the stage too
it says I remember I remember seeing
everybody good Smee this be a real good
match
yeah
terma the sweet spot of that spear right
then your only hope
oh my goodness whoa I'm account i'm
account that is read because it was
poked up all the reason
Kahn saying you gotta get a couple hits
in before he knocks yeah oh also I
didn't realize but I was looking through
the patch notes
Oh too far apparently like every
character had their shield size buffed
is so interesting a weird choice that I
definitely don't understand the things
for what everyone was like like a
general product of the show sighs okay
like everyone had like a shield size
increase to buy like an actual like
proper percent apparently squirrels is
too big for now it's I haven't seen it
yet
yeah well Oh No Zeno's I've seen which
to be fair I've missed a few because I
was too keen stuff that was a face
detection he's taking down this greninja
that was real good was a good fight
Claude would be proud
[Applause]
I think you should have Tim Tams time
times would be interesting to see you
like get a Pokemon fight time time never
pretty good
contender cocking early about Jotaro oh
sure I missed it
well what happened jeweler Oh what are
they saying I would never suspect you're
a Cujo or any judge of character
Oh I mean how they even do the art style
cuz I could stop talking about
characters and smash that have Jojo
energy and actually just pick a joechip
except a soccer eyes a lot like Jake no
anime yeah smash is only for girls and
boys don't think Jordan who Joe is he's
he's good but he's not a good boy
just call his mom a [ __ ] yeah that's
kind of what I'm thinking about you know
[Laughter]
that and all the murder
you put Joseph in there though he's a
really good boy you gotta think about
its final smash though alright yeah uh
just over everything
Oh that'd be real good also say what you
will about that wacky weird three the
anime fighting game something started so
real yeah real rough art sodding Unreal
Engine they did the Jojo characters very
well animated that's it I've heard it's
not a good game but it's like a it's
very good fanservice II like Jojo damn
it it's also kind of like maybe one of
my favorite like anime Arena Fighter
games to play I do not like playing
I don't either which is why it's it's a
heck of a thing but right they did a
good job with like calories just to make
it actually more than just mashing
buttons this is all right this is enough
for me to actually kind of quality with
a finisher now Franco Franco do this
with a banjo I hope so
oh he's got he's got those four jumps he
can do that that's fine
this is okay oh this is realized how
that would be it
no I'm holding my breath [ __ ] I'd only
do
hey any move could do it
[Music]
[Music]
way to go Franco dethroned alias Haley
she had a very good run that was ha but
that was a hell way to bring the new era
a new badge O'Hara oh man that that was
amazing the best best man should well
done both of yous sure Wow
oh I'm feeling it
when we come back out frozen the desert
still playing oh man oh man oh man
[Applause]
do we know that Jojo or banjo has Jojo
waltz there they're a couple of thing
that could be the real banjo just like a
like a do one I remember all the the
Jojo memes that came out around the time
that banjo did involving them he's very
good
[Applause]
bamm-bamm Jojo stages real good it also
makes me remember that I kind of missed
Tamagotchi
oh we've had a frank one chase fight
each other before - this is a bit of a
run back
[Music]
[Music]
just plain funny Tamagotchi at all
oh you should all really play - now I'm
kind of like watching I didn't play any
but I remember hearing about it when he
came out I think there's the 3d x1 right
yeah yeah and I remember things like
sounds interesting but I just like
packed it up and so as a wacky time
[Music]
someone around what what are fighting
like fighting game careful in Smash so
now they've got ten were you we've got
turbo guard and maybe someone from Soul
Calibur maybe that is the next one link
was in Soul Calibur too long game so
caliber them you know I would probably
go with like amateur he went up yeah for
facing people nightmare night there are
a lot of people thinking that I think
that's a good call like more more heavy
sword use repeat yeah so Ike's got a
real heavy sword
piloff has got kind of like a silver
sword play style who's the one with the
staff and he look Sheila key which is
always my favorite in Soul Calibur 2
apart from link of course geez
yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
a good fight for the pie chase yeah more
banjo is never a bad is it me none
you're almost there up next though it's
show boy don't play the next round ban
Oh next rotation I could I could
probably jump in for one yeah I'm down
what character did you have set though
if you've got time
we got time yeah we got about 15 minutes
left some me maybe maybe not we'll see
the Dragon Quest
I'm still having a very good time
playing that it's good I still finished
it I'm gonna get back to it it is long
but still very much enjoying it I think
it's Pokemon came at a night now I threw
me off the fire yeah I I'm kind of
worried because I started like feel like
I'm going off sequence for it the the
next story recommendation for me has
been a different place but I want to
actually follow this to some curious mo
interesting we might want to reset the
arena after you fight there's a couple
more people about one trying to them big
will do that then maybe we'll just do
yeah after my fight we do reset and then
can get in beg up
[Music]
after Franco beats me yeah
my wizard hat Pikachu
[Applause]
[Music]
in the original super specialist visit
fat Pikachu as its own Pikachu I take it
was Lucy choo choo
yeah maybe a mix between even though
Batman she is still in the ones about
that boy
[Music]
I also caught like the theory that like
original pictures like hope to be a
Pikachu and I mean oh yeah there's some
sort of thing oh yeah yeah that's that's
some good kind of weird deep smash with
his Lord I mean yeah it's like the one
in Brawl does that mean the Pikachu from
melee got too old that's the part I
don't want to think about I feel weird
some like trying to look at the
background and trying to find places
that I recognize go huh there it is
all right cake yeah it looks like it was
chunky Pikachu heck yeah yeah
[Applause]
[Music]
well what do you think of the new
starter Dynomax forms Oh for the DLC
yeah
you got the home-field advantage here
[Music]
every time I see that that a combo I
can't not think about that like the fact
that it goes to like the speed of the
banjo and the theme just got the same
like sounds like a chicken going on
that's really cool touch yeah they
didn't have to do that but they did and
I appreciate it
good for them
[Music]
man I had the counter time too
who
so I am curious about these other
fireman characters because they all have
these these runs that have them like
almost horizontal to the ground I don't
know if that's like a like a thing we
doing we all hold your game except the
older games but I never really I guess a
little put enough thought to it
and now I'm kind of like a wacky way
just like an anime style
[Applause]
[Music]
music is appropriately intense
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
possessive roll hard match for me to
walk like cuz I want I want the engine
to win Costanza but I want Jake to win
because Jake oh no he's close I came
back at the end but and didn't make a
difference gonna come back all right why
don't we run a clue the lobby and then
pass the controller to been cleared the
lobby and why don't we set it back to
one cuz we only have 10 minutes boom for
real quick okay good matches everyone
and here so far
yeah you think you're gonna play part
this
I'll pick snake and then change this
enemy I'm not too particular about what
Cory's
give you like best camouflage my camo
index is high like that big notification
the top think Dex knew that was wipe
everyone just wipe it all out wrapping
it clean oh man everyone are you doing
feel free to join if you want to keep
going it's the last chance there you go
alright
Ben's playing now he's taken over so
please direct all your angry upset you
don't know what you're doing comments
Wow someone's name god this is the and a
smash King is here
oh wait of bits home I feel bad for
decks or deck I think he had just joined
like I kicked him right away so it's
just clearing the lobby
I apologize only could fit more people I
know
if we didn't get to you this today we're
very sorry unfortunately we're never
able to get to everyone
[Music]
and it would make sense that I'd be
fighting war you ready to be that's just
yeah that's just that's just science
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
nice whoa good job man I did really well
killing it just gets cuz of the camera
Windex it was real hard to see me that's
that's the only reason
Jake snakes it's really good Jake this
hog huh
you're not playing banjo but that's
understandable but I appreciate your
name very much
[Music]
this will blow myself up really quick
[Music]
tim was saying I don't think you can
join after you get kicked since I don't
see the arena and well that's it we're
almost standing you're honest I am oh no
that's good to know for the future
though that if that's how it works then
I guess we won't mass kick people will
just kick you in the playing a lot we've
been in a lot it's not on the ground I
definitely put it on them okay
everything's fine it wasn't fine oh no
that's that's what you get what you play
snake sometimes the sea pours on you I
love that okay oh man good fight though
you're baile thisvery frightening and I
probably would have actually gotten
beaten yeah Topanga how fast this goes
that that might have been the last match
we get to play the rest of them might
just be ones we get to watch probably
that's okay yeah
yeah we're gonna see more Donkey Kong
that's what I'm here for to taste
getting credit requests it's a good day
to go home so much
[Music]
get that that stuff is
[Music]
this is another little hard for me
because I want to walk governor win
because I also want document what's a
win win then it really is
[Music]
[Applause]
oh I was waiting for that that spirit of
to poke out there was it back in all
honesty this may be the best way that
it's ended up with some really good
violent gameplay because yeah
appropriate the whole point of the thing
we got it all so I don't think any of us
have really picked that color for viola
Thea yeah I like that color I didn't
think I liked it on the portrait but
seeing it yeah that's good it's a good
good color good outfit I guess the smash
King is here about someone playing
Ridley we're saying that people there it
is this this is smash King's moment
they've been waiting for Ridley the
whole time and they finally got them in
special ever since we were talking [ __ ]
about Ridley no I'm playing in there I
got I got to get anything out of show
and I'll let him know
rich really crew is here
people really does have that really cool
side feeling of just drags yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
sonic vegan which matches still wild
already bro yeah that was a while ago
yeah snake was Wilder when they've
brought snake in I was like yeah that
was no way that was the crazy one for
sure and then when they took it out for
me you I was like well you know I mean
it was kind of too good to be true
anyway yeah everyone's here trailer yeah
bye everyone but they show snake for a
while and I was like but does every way
include snake because he wasn't in the
last lesson is that the same girl that
were pop-up Wharf snake specifically
because if that was on everyone didn't
believe whatever happened yeah I think I
wanted yeah it was like they were going
through the mall and you're like this is
everyone you're like this person can't
be here and then it was like no and then
they showed snake everyone's here whoa
yeah yep they got snake they got it tank
there's the really gameplay yeah yeah we
called for it they're there I think we
can probably watch at least one more
match one more match one more match oh
that's too much
oh we have to a threw it I didn't
realize oh you don't have to it'll count
down eventually but I think it just
slows things down probably does it make
a difference because it's still way too
oh the best Pokemon battle that's Mewtwo
what type is ridley dragon doesn't easy
go to be a dragon yeah it's all very
like a steel dragon yeah yeah yeah
they're you steel dragon pokémon and
heavy a cool type
[Music]
there was the I mean in a hidden shield
the gym the dragon gym leader has that
steel pokemons but I don't think it's a
bracket thing oh yeah no it is got der a
load on yeah that is that steel okay
it's a steel dragon yeah I forgot
oh no the other one that's kind of
disappointing cuz I don't really like
der a load on that much now I'm
picturing like a Ridley with armor yeah
[Music]
knowing that was a quick one does that
mean you get one more oh we could do one
more one more
we'll end it on one more one more one
more song I mean game yeah yeah yeah
yeah and I think that gives almost
everyone a chance sounds like Anthony I
forgot to find you
no Anthony was the one we thought the
game oh nevermind everyone gets a chance
to fight it's perfect I think that's
everyone
I don't remember what was happening I'm
still hung up on the fact that I blew
myself up
Oh more by left - perfect
and if I'm back
[Music]
philo first ridley my favorite chapter
in firing three houses pretty cannon
fight on the duck hunt stage just like I
remember
I'm excited for the three houses DLC me
too
I feel like I've just had enough time
we're gonna finish that game and when
that DLC is coming out - yeah it's like
a separate campaign right you have to
start a new game or do it I think so and
also the like story implications are
real weird because you say it's like
these students we're just living
underground this whole time yeah beyond
that because they're in the sewers
something like your whole party is is
the house leaders and apparently like
well we decided to set aside the
differences and become friends and now
they like main party it'll be really how
they explain that but knowing a fire
emblem they won't explain it it'll just
be that's how it is yeah travel or
something
[Applause]
fail that looks like something that you
definitely try to kill dragon so that
seems like that's a good point
Oh smash King this Twitter we can get
alias and smash Queen each other no
ma'am that we're gonna fight for the
ages close it out yeah thank you
everyone for playing with us
there's been really good a lot of fun
yeah anytime we bring smash I will
definitely have to bring it out again
next time they they have a character or
if just you know nothing else is
happening it's doable thanks for joining
us Jake of course thank you for having
me is a lot of fun yeah absolutely and
yeah Tim you guys I'm an incall you
working on uh don't be a fool stay in
school
octagon and rhomboid check out GameSpot
after dark it's now on YouTube too so
you can find it there or if you don't
like watching podcast be fair I don't
either then you can just go on to iTunes
Spotify whatever podcasters you want and
give it a listen
we had Zach Ryan from IGN on we talked a
lot about violet and super smash bros
cool yeah and if you want to watch
another community fridays we do one
every friday
nine hundred percent sure we're doing
next week you're thinking about PSO but
it sounds like it might come out kind of
the end of the day so maybe we'll do you
Joker from Mortal Kombat we'll see but
yeah it's taking forever and thanks for
watching
[Music]